[Music]
today's question comes from roberto in
texas says
i've always helped my immediate family
members if they needed money and most
have paid me back but i have two
siblings that have borrowed nine
thousand bucks through the years without
paying back a cent and neither of them
work
my brother has used the kidney failure
his kidney failure as an excuse for the
past 20 years and my sister has recently
been diagnosed with diabetes and is
going down the same path
i made a promise to my parents that i
would look out for my siblings but i
feel like enough is enough
how can i let them know i will no longer
come to their aid unless they pay for
their past debt
all right dave i
can i answer this and you can you can
beat up my answer
yeah or vice versa
um
making you promise your parents you take
care of them
it looks like you are contributing to
them uh
very negative health outcomes
so if i'm this young man or if he was my
brother or my friend i would tell him
forgive the debt and sit him down and
say i'm not going to give any more money
to anybody and then move on with your
life
yep
so here's the i mean is that right yeah
now this is not a um
a proper uh
psychological
definition
and so you can shoot holes in this
but in my opinion
number one enablers that i have met
including when i have been an enabler um
and i can think of a time recently that
i did that
lord forgive me and shoot me in the head
if i try to do that again but um
uh enablers when we are enablers any of
us
it is when we are the nicest people in
the world
we are too nice to say no
and in the name of being nice
we get run over like doormats and we
call that being nice we're really good
at it in the south yeah bless your heart
bless your heart bless your heart which
can mean i'm getting results your throat
or it could mean bless your heart
we don't know what it means it depends
on the tone and the context and
everything else and then you may still
may not know so um when my wife says
bless your heart i still i'm not sure
after 40 years what she means
sometimes it's sarcastic and i do
understand but bless your heart i know
what that means okay but um
that means you are a dumb butt yeah
that's um but but the uh uh anyway
enablers this man is a nice man that's
right number one
number two
this is this part that's probably not
psychologically correct in my opinion
someone who is enabling
they always say i always hear the
language i'm helping
they want me to help i want to help
i told my parents i would take care of
them help them
be there for them
and that i think enablers have defined
help wrong
absolutely
i think enablers help use other people
as tools to make themselves feel good
yeah but i mean
if you think giving a drunk a drink is
helping them you have defined help wrong
right
you've harmed
the person that's right you've
contributed to it right you've brought
gastroenterology participating in their
crazy butt behavior right
now i don't know about the kidney
failure i don't know about the diabetes
i don't know what's going on here i'm
not a medical doctor
uh diabetes comes from a lot of
different things obesity is one of them
sure
um and they don't work much he said in
both their cases i think so i mean i i
don't know it could be in the in the
equation here but i i i'm not gonna i
can't make a prognostic prognostication
or however you say that on a prediction
on their health or or even read motive
into their health but i i can go um
these people are not sustaining their
own lives and so i am participating in
their failure by giving them money not
only are they not sustaining their own
lives but i'm watching the quality of
their life decrease and i am paying for
i'm paying for it that's right so i'm
contributing to this yeah it's giving a
drunk a drink it's buying a heroin
addict some heroin right
i mean when you're participating in
their when you're enabling or causing or
making it easier for
their negative behavior to continue
my son lives in my basement and he won't
get a job well what if he wasn't in your
basement
oh yeah you're contributing
because a an eagle that doesn't leave
the nest is eventually known as a turkey
kick is butt out why because you're a
big old meanie and that's tough love no
because you do love him so much that you
know he will have no dignity as a 46
year old in your basement he already
doesn't have any dignity as a 26 year
old in your basement get his little butt
out
and i would reverse it i would reverse
this too roberto and say
stop using your brother and sister as a
way to reconnect with your parents
right your parents um now we just got
hochikuchi with the psychology our
pastor they passed away stop using your
brother and sister and giving them money
leading to what david was talking about
leading to them having challenges stop
doing that don't use your brother and
sister anymore and don't become you're
not a loan shark to your brother and
sister yeah yeah just that money spent i
would just say yeah i agree with john on
that just i call him say listen it's
forgiven i'm not going to give you any
more because i love you because i love
you and what i will do is i will cheer
for you i'll help you i'll coach you
i'll show you how to get a job i'll show
you how to interview for a job i'll
teach you the character you need to keep
the job i'll help you with your budget
i'll help you get out of debt by showing
you how i'll pay for you to go to
financial peace university um if you
want to take a class at the community
college and to get to get that job i'll
pay for that i'll go to the doctor with
you when he explo when the doctor went
here she explains how you're going to
navigate your health crisis and work
right we'll figure all that out
i'll be there with you i'm i'm there for
i love you yeah i'm not cutting you off
emotionally and relationally i'm cutting
you off financially
and the only reason i'm doing that is
because i love you so much
well that's tough love no honey that's
just love just love this is love what
you're doing is not love enabling is not
love it's called cowardice right
uh you don't have the backbone to say no
and you're blaming your parents cause
it's using people yeah don't do that
don't do that so yeah enablers are the
nicest people in the world even when i'm
an enabler i'm that's when i'm my nicest
i'm because you're too wimpy
to do the conflict to say
dude you need to get a job this stops
you're my brother you freaking lazy you
need to get up get your big butt off the
couch here man or if you've got if
you've got kidney failure we need to go
get you with some services that are
going to get you the help that you need
man this isn't working yeah and what
what kind of income producing thing can
you do yeah with that because it's not
sustainable right it's not sustainable
and there's no
dignity i was about to say i'm writing
down dignity restoration this is how you
give someone the gift of dignity yeah
right here's 73 books to read
that will motivate you and i'll read
them with you right i
will do this together we'll have a bible
study together i'll pick you up and
we'll go to church
raise our hands and praise jesus and you
know let's do it look what we got to do
let's get this thing moving called life
i'm here in your corner i'm for you but
what's happening is you're becoming
embittered toward them over nine grand
forgive the nine grand forget that it's
gone you ain't getting it back number
one number two it's holding you back
from moving them forward